i remember one time you went on tv right
you went on on tv and you looked so
[ __ ] even but that's not makeup they
actually put filters on oh yeah yeah
that interview you did on
ctv yeah that was a whole filter yeah
you know what i'm talking about right tv
does that has a whole filter yeah they
even out they do this weird stuff to
your face it filters out and you look
unnatural
it's like you don't let people have
their wrinkles that people have their
yeah
like what's the issue oh my god you look
the same on tv then yeah because
yeah but they have their standards and
they don't change so you don't think
until somebody else comes along and
smashes the whole thing yeah it's like
when netflix came along and smashed the
whole like you have to do one episode
every week and they just drop that [ __ ]
all at the same time people love that
they're like oh we can do this i can
binge yeah people like binge watching
it's like [ __ ] off
so i think a lot of stuff on television
that just
yeah yeah but as far as makeup goes like
makeup rough number one oh yeah
comes close changing the way you look
makeup makeup makeup
makeup i have old sri lankan and indian
weddings where the lady starts out black
she does her makeup she's white she's a
white lady with a bendy in the middle of
her forehead yeah
i would argue that maybe
hair is like a second close not even
dying dying i'm sorry dying is never
going to be as big as cutting her hair
true the difference between having super
long hair and no hair or just a shape up
yes just a shape up it don't have to be
drastic for men you just have a shape up
you get your line done yeah she all
shaded like laser oh
you feel like a million bucks the only
thing missing is about a million dollars
yeah it changed the whole [ __ ] i will
put dying like towards the bottom of
that true i would put working out even
before that somebody who like completely
changed the way that they look
physically that looks night and day hair
is just like okay you you want this but
even even working now just
it doesn't necessarily change you
physically but the fact that you feel
better about yourself like just the
first time you you work out and you did
a good session you didn't shift in
weights or whatever what not but your
confidence makes you
feel some type of it makes you feel some
type of way and you're right like you
you just you just glow the glow up is
nice yeah so yeah even that not even
like physically but just the glow up
these [ __ ] boomers bro like boomers
plastic surgery you want to talk about
changing [ __ ] you can have a new face
permanently straight up wow
yeah wild right
i i met somebody recently who i didn't
know i knew
really you know what i mean
because of the platform i saw their face
i was like oh i've never met this person
and then i looked at old pictures like
oh i know this person is you yeah that
drastic ah yeah just people are over
doing it and it's becoming so
commonplace that you're starting to
notice like even regular folks just
casually just getting titty jobs getting
their lips done or getting their ass
done bbl's yeah yeah yeah bbl's are
really popular
insane ones where it's like okay calm
down yeah come calm down stick legs
basketball we know when the thighs don't
match the booty we know yeah we know
yeah no one has a natural big booty and
skinny legs that never doesn't work like
that no no there's a proportion to
everything that has to make sense and
i've always kind of come to accept that
because
the skin around it stretches in a way
that doesn't make sense
you feel what i'm saying there's like a
disproportionate like that's not real
it's not possible yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah i'm looking at that same
thing with the lips yeah
when someone gets a lip top like the way
the skin pulls you can just tell them
because
there's something unnatural about it
like i've seen one with big lips
naturally and i'm like it looks a
certain yeah when you don't do it
naturally there's like a way that it
pulls it yeah it's weird it's not that
yeah it's just
they haven't perfected but that's
actually the aesthetic that they're
trying to look for you're trying to go
for that aesthetic and it doesn't really
look like
it doesn't look
natural yeah but that's an aesthetic
lady trying to everybody that got lip
injection right now their lips look the
same their lips look kind of the same
even the ones that say like now i want
lip suggestion but i want my [ __ ] to
look like natural and i'm like
okay i could tell doesn't look natural
there's a girl here like a youtuber here
from montreal like this white girl and
she had her stuff done and i was like
you look at her like you can tell yeah
it looks very faint because she had no
lips so if you go from nowhere to
someone's like oh okay reasonable then
you look at her lipstick it looks weird
yeah it looks off
you know but for these people it makes
sense to them and the thing about lip
injections is it one of my homies i
don't think it's what you're almost okay
never mind you have to do them often
yeah cause because you're because your
body consumes that silicone yep it's
[ __ ] up and that's dangerous because i
think that could create cancer and [ __ ]
like that um
yeah fillers fillers both a friend of
mine who like there's still some in
there and it still like has effects on
her
yeah people are doing wild stuff to
their bodies um and i'm just like listen
i get it you know there's a lot of
pressure but i'm like that's nasty
that's nasty yeah
and kind of like you said like you end
up looking like the same person like
there's like you're trying to achieve
this particular aesthetic that isn't
natural the goal isn't to look like
better but natural to look like this
weird
like like instagram like there's like
this instagram like [ __ ] doll look you
know what i mean where it's like
everyone wants to look like that yeah
you ever see that south korean um
like uh miss south korea in like 2018 or
something they had a picture of
everyone's face like went viral and they
all looked identical
it's slightly different than the western
instagram thing where it's like big
stuff because they're all about like
softening you know yeah but until they
still go to the they still go to their
uh uh
surgeon and they'd be like
make make this exactly do this
and everybody's like they have the same
reference do this
and you know that's what they do they
just they just go and do exactly
replicate that you walk through certain
areas of soul you're like i saw that
girl over there i saw her there you're
like i just clones it's just clones it's
wild and now now they get the they get
the boob job and they get the lipo for
the rest because they they really want
to look like stick figures in the bottom
and big turtles
yeah so they all a lot of them look like
that it's crazy the same face yeah same
face it's not even something racist they
all look alike no no they all look a lot
like you know